Wow, this is looking great.
I think you both did a great job
in version one, I mean point one.
>> Mm-hm,
yeah actually it was super easy.
It was just a matter of
installing the SDK and
getting her up to sync the Firebase.
>> Well,
you've also done your homework, and
Firebase seems to be a great choice
considering your requirements.
>> That is true.
And you know what,
we've been doing so much work,
I think it's time for a break.
I could really use some sleep, and
there's actually some shows
I've wanted to catch up on.
>> Hey [CROSSTALK].
>> So yeah, we downloaded the app, and I
got some friends to download it too, and
we're really confused.
>> Category keeps overriding
the name of my shopping list.
>> Okay,
well could this wait until tomorrow?
>> No.
No it cannot wait because
Jeff has been trying to order toilet
paper since, I don't know, an hour ago?
So you need to fix it.
No, no, excuse me.
Fix it!
Fix it! Fix it! >> Alright I'll fix it!
>> So, on to version point two.